what does better for your comedy having
a Netflix special or going on Rogan the
Rogan
thing is good but it used to be bigger
you know like before the Spotify so I'd
say it if the Netflix special clicks
like Segura just put one out and it was
in the top ten for two three weeks it
was huge number one number one yeah and
it's Global you know that thing goes out
to the whole goddamn world there's some
guy in a Hut in India going hey this
guy's funny and then Rogan is also great
but if the special is good I think the
special beats it but there's a lot of
bad specials out there there's a ton of
bad specials out there so if your
special's bad I think Rogan's better